hoje convidei os meus amigos para um
teste de QI eles vão passar por cinco
testes de inteligência que até um
tiktoker consegui resolver Será que o QI
deles está mais perto do Einstein ou de
um bu no primeiro desafio eles têm que
inverter o sentido do Triângulo apenas
tocando em três moedas esa aí
[Música]
eh só posso mexer três moedas só três
moedas 1 2
3 dois trê mas aqui mais três pôr um não
[Risadas]
dá se eu tirar Isto não posso dar posso
andar à volta podes podes
[Música]
mano já tá eu não vi eu não vi eu não vi
v filho da mãe puto tens 1 minuto e meio
a Olha aí não
[Risadas]
quer
bem
[Música]
uau ficou
[Risadas]
igual É sério esta para aqui esa mano
pronto aqui já tá invertida para mim
Pronto já
[Música]
tá eu avisei S ano
era desafio eles têm que tornar este no
num se sem apagar e sem estragar o que
já está escrito preciso transformar isto
num se sem atropelar nada sem riscá-lo
sim sem riscar o que tá
aí tem que ficar seis tem que ficar um
se se isto é um bom início ou não
supostamente isto seria
Não
Para Não D
assim
[Música]
[__] tens 15 segundos 15 segundos e
já fiz merda e
[Música]
agora agora eu quero ver como é que eu
faço isto mover aqui mano tipo como é
que eu faço eu até meti os números em
venezuelano para perceber sim sim
[Música]
sim atropelei então não é tu passaste a
linha por cima do
10 segundos n espera não fales isso não
digas isso ó mano is parece-me um seis
BR What onde é que estás
[Música]
a isso é um seis o quê essa é a segunda
mais fácil cas é a segunda mais fácil
[Música]
teu não consigo eu deo acabou o tempo
ya não D mano não sei sabes
não te
[__] [__] seis mano neste desafio
eles têm que formar um quadrado apenas
movendo um palito mano isso é possível
meui man não fui eui eu e Mano Aposto
que tem a ver alguma coisa tipo
[Música]
tens 10 segundos 10 meso 10 só
palito feito onde que quadrado no centro
retângul
quado bo
acert muitos
[Música]
parabéns 30 segundos o quê Já passou 2
minutos Ah pois é tá sem passar tão
rápido enquanto pensas o tempo passa
rápido o tempo passa [__] olha D passar
ar
boa 4 3 2 1 explodiu ali o quadrado ali
não M eu sabia eu sabia era este mano e
se era isso bro já tinha lá chegado há
muito tempo só se for o quadrado do Meio
boa
Pronto ele passou ele passou foi das
primeiras coisas que eu pensei
tipo neste desafio eles têm de desenhar
um círculo e um ponto sem levantar a
caneta da folha
Hum mas como é que eu vou fazer eu acho
que isto é dobrar tipo só não podes
levantar a caneta imagina tipo eu estou
tou estou a riscar e risco a madeira
[Música]
posso não olhes para mim
sem levantar a caneta e é sem levantar a
[__] da
caneta porque aí consigo mas o problema
é o ponto lá no
meio como é que isto é possível sequer
sem levantar a
caneta Olha o origami é boa solução Ou
seja no momento em que toco no papel já
perdi então não posso tocar no
papel ten levantar a Abou o risco out a
mesa
mano levantou ali levantou mano ó puto
porque não tá bem dobrada mano a partir
daí levantaste a caneta mas não é
levantar não é assim não não podes
levantar da folha da folha Ok mas então
é qualquer coisa
assim dobrar é estúpido estás a
ver mano isso saiu do contacto com a
folha mano ai o que é isso não perdeste
cas desculpa lá não vale mano não
aí ai acabou
perdeste posso fazer assim
experimento isto é uma cena vossa não é
[Música]
ya acabou já perdeste não não levantou
boa vamos embora seis também não vai boa
mano Boa ya não o ponto altera se rodar
a folha mano de facto isso ui ui ui ui
olha olha olha ui ui ui ui não levantei
não levantei e rasguei a folha mano mano
tem um buraco aqui no meio ó [__] porque
pronto a tinta né pá eu vou contar ele
passou esta vamos
embora eia
[Música]
bem acertaste
claro que
não ESA est aí o ponto agora esa pera
pera sabes onde é que tá o ponto tá ali
olha ol
ali neste desafio eles têm que levantar
o copo acima da cabeça apenas podem usar
dois dedos e não podem deixar cair as
moedas vão cair
puto a moeda pode estar aqui de lado
então eu posso pegar nelas fazer assim
tenta
[__]
sem
cair e
[Música]
[Aplausos]
já me
dei Pronto boa bem jogado isso claro já
tá feito eu pensava que tu me ias dizer
que isso não valia
ok
boa
a ui ui ui
ah acabou perdeu já então boa oi
boa não
[Música]
acredito eu não acredito eu não
acredito comentem aí quem é que vocês
acham que foi o melhor nestas provas e
até o próximo vídeo